the FBI has concluded its investigation
into allegations against Brett Kavanaugh
the White House finds no corroborating
evidence for the charges senators flake
and Collins say the investigation was
thorough
cocaine Mitch sets the cloture vote for
Friday and we could all have a confirmed
Associate Justice Kavanaugh by Saturday
which leaves me with one very serious
message for Senate Democrats hahaha
you lost nice try you shameless jackals
we will examine the Leftwich trial of
Judge Cavanaugh as it passes into the
rearview mirror then a male feminists
roundhouse kicks a pro-life woman
presumably because of how much he
supports women finally the mailbag and a
psalm of life on National Poetry Day I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
get your tumblers already folks get them
ready mmm here we go
so it's all falling apart the FBI
investigation is done Time magazine is
running a cover story this just came out
yesterday I believe how Christine Blasi
Ford's testimony changed America which
coincidentally is going to be the title
of my new book it's gonna be a wonderful
sequel very similar content to my first
book didn't change nothing baby
I mean it humiliated Democrats who
really thought they had something they
stooped even lower than they usually do
and now it looks like it's all turning
out for the best of course anything
could still happen in the next few days
but right now things are going pretty
well why do I think that let's turn to
Senate Democrat Chris Coons to explain
the situation do you believe this red
Cavanaugh will because I know what you
hope you hope he does it but do you
believe he will I think this will be a
very close vote it hangs by a few
undecided Democrats and Republicans I
haven't read this report yet if I were
to just guest today he will be narrowly
confirmed oh oh did you hear that at the
end if I had to guess today he will be
narrowly confirmed ha ha ha before we go
on before we analyze this a little
further and have a little recap of all
this shameful witch trial come on into
my boudoir baby let's talk about Boleyn
branch sheets you know I just got a new
bed you need some nice sheets on that
bed I love Boleyn brand sheets they are
so good
everything that Boleyn branch makes from
the bedding to the blankets is made from
100% pure organic cotton that means that
they start out supersoft they get even
softer over time luxury sheets can cost
up to $1,000 even more I didn't know
this obviously when I was a derelict a
single man I would sleep on I don't know
tissue paper sand paper or whatever I
could find but really nice sheets are
worth it they feel really good always
look you spend a lot of your life on
your bed people most people spend a
third of their life I spend about a
closer to three thirds of my life on my
bed you want to make sure that you have
really high quality stuff there everyone
who tries Boleyn branch will love some
it's why they have thousands of
five-star reviews Forbes Wall Street
Journal Fast Company all talk about
Boleyn branch three u.s. presidents
sleep on Boland branch sheets try to
guess which ones
is free to try for 30 nights if you
don't love him send it back for a refund
you will love them though right now my
listeners get $50 off your first set of
sheets invite me into your boudoir get
$50 off Bolan branch comp promo code
Michael mi CH AE L go to Boleyn branch
comm today $50 off first set of sheets
Bo LL and branch comm promo code Michael
sorry mr. Koontz he's gonna be weeping
into his sheets pretty soon it's so so
sad for them isn't it the FBI has
completed that supplemental
investigation now did they need to do
the investigation no judge Cavanaugh had
already had six FBI investigations but
after those hearings you know there were
these new allegations that came out from
Christine Ford and that crazy person
from avenatti and all these other people
and so the White House or the FBI did
this separate investigation the White
House confirmed late last night it was
reported in the Wall Street Journal that
they found no corroborating evidence
whatsoever centered over the Senate
chuck Grassley said there was no
corroborating evidence whatsoever Mitch
McConnell yesterday cocaine Mitch set
the vote for cloture crucially now we've
got Jeff Flake that little Quisling Jeff
Flake is saying there's no corroboration
so it seems like he's going to vote for
Cavanaugh Susan Collins same thing said
the investigation seems very thorough so
looks like we can hope that a show vote
for Cavanaugh which means that it looks
like mr. Cavanaugh is going to the
Supreme Court of the United States for
reaction we turn to the entire Senate
Democratic caucus
to introduce anywhere the 40mm that's
about what I expected but it's still
very enjoyable to to see that again one
second hmm very very good they're still
furious though the Democrats and the
senator still furious and the Democrat
partisans around the country are still
furious now serious Democrats and I've
talked to a number of them did not put a
lot of stock into these allegations for
many reasons which we'll get to a little
later I mean we've we've gone over all
of the reasons not to and now we have no
corroboration whatsoever of any of them
even by the people who were named in the
allegation so I think serious Democrats
didn't actually take the allegations
seriously but they use them as a
political tool it's a little dirty it's
a little nasty but understandable what
really worries me are the Democrats who
took them seriously in the first place
who were so gullible or so willfully
ignorant that they would go along with
what were obvious lies or
misrepresentations and untruths and
stories that have more holes in them
than Swiss cheese that's that's a little
sad and so those people are now calling
for all the same stuff they want another
a longer FBI investigation a more
thorough FBI investigation because now
they say the Supplemental FBI
investigation didn't investigate Ford
and Cavanaugh
okay so this is their new line it didn't
investigate forwarding Cavanagh to begin
what is an FBI investigation I think
people you know people throw that work
that phrase around I don't think they
know what it means it's when the FBI
comes and interviews you and gets
statements from you and then they say
okay what did this happen did this
happen to this happen and then they just
print the reports percentage those
statements the FBI investigations here
don't reach conclusions as Joe Biden
famously said in 1991 so they didn't
interview Ford and Cavanaugh why not
well because we've already heard from
Ford and Cavanaugh under oath before the
Senate Judiciary Committee for hours and
hours and hours
Christine Ford testified for four hours
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
about Brett Kavanaugh he testified for
32 hours we have a lot of testimony or
so I think
the left is suggesting now is that the
FBI would go up to them and say so
doctor or Ford did you mean it did you
mean everything you said yes I meant it
yeah okay and you sure though yes what
question are they gonna ask her that
wasn't asked during the hearing or that
wasn't given in the opening statements
what are they gonna ask Brett Kavanaugh
that he didn't get asked or talked about
in 32 hours of testimony is there
anything like he went over everything
went over his favorite drinks in college
you know he went over the definition of
boo thing there is nothing left to talk
about so there's nothing new to get here
now they've tried to have they've saved
their last minute desperate hail-mary
here it is
they've got Brett Kavanaugh his old
sweet mate at Yale I guess someone used
to live with him or live near him at
Yale his name is Kenneth appaled and I
guess I guess life didn't treat Kenneth
very well after his halcyon days in New
Haven so he decides he needs to get 15
minutes of fame trying to dunk on his
former classmate and so he says now you
remember that Debbie Ramirez allegation
this is another one that came up like
five seconds ago then no one had ever
heard about for 30 years and so what she
said is that Cavanaugh was at a party
and he whipped it out one time and that
whipped out little Brett and there was
no corroboration of this people refuted
it there's no evidence that it happened
but now Kenneth appaled the former suite
mate or classmate of Brett Cavanaugh
says that he is 100% certain that some
guy told him about that she catch that
last part because I know if you only
heard the first part you think Wow okay
he's there's a witness no no no he
wasn't there he wasn't in the room where
this alleged whipping out happened he
just is 100% certain that he heard about
it as a rumor from some guy later on who
allegedly was in a room but it gets
better because of the New Yorker you
know Ronan Farrow who used to be a
serious guy and now he's reporting these
ridiculous rumors to try to torpedo a
Supreme Court nominee a conservative
Supreme Court nominee crucially he
reported this - so the New Yorker
reaches out
to the guy that that app hold allegedly
heard the rumor from cuz appaled
couldn't get ahold of the guy The New
Yorker finally gets in touch with him
and the guy that appaled heard the rumor
from denies ever having said it or
remembering said I have no recollection
of that whatsoever so he refutes the
guys claim but Apple does 100% certain
that he heard a rumor 35 years ago from
some guy who says it never happened haha
it's so good I'm sorry it's so so good
so now the new one they want the new the
new demand so that the FBI thing so it
didn't work out and I got to tell you
something I've been really harsh on Jeff
like this week I'm still feeling pretty
harsh on Jeff Flake because he's a
little squish and he got us into a very
dangerous situation where crazy
allegations could have come out of the
woodwork to delay delay even more
fortunately public opinion was against
it but the flake thing did work out
right the flake extra week seems to have
helped Republicans in the polls we'll
get to that in a little bit I don't know
that that lets him off the hook for
pulling such a reckless move but all in
all it worked out so I'm happy about
that so the FBI thing didn't work out
the ice fight at the New Haven bar that
one didn't work out the New York Times
scoop that he you know raised a beer keg
over his head didn't work out so now now
the Democrats have one last strategy
that they're going to affect which we'll
get to in a second but before we do that
I have got to thank our friends over at
Dollar Shave Club you know I love Dollar
Shave Club look at my little baby face
look how soft it is because I use my
favorite razor that I've ever used the
executive six blade razor from Dollar
Shave no matter what you do in the
bathroom to get ready Dollar Shave Club
has everything you need to look feel and
smell your best I use it all the time
they've got the amber and lavender body
wash they've got the big cloud good
shake hand cream boogies pacific pomade
is really good i'll I mean I do love
this razor so much the executive razor
shave butter can help too they've got
everything and they've got those one
wipe Charlies you know what those I use
them all the time to remove my makeup
thank you very much ru if I come back
from a news hit or my show I use it to
remove my makeup you're also supposed to
use it on the other end of your body as
a sort of portable bed
a disposable bidet the one wipe Charlies
indispensable right now you can get
ready with an amazing deal on any one of
Dollar Shave Club starter sets
I recommend the daily essentials starter
set because of the amber lavender body
cleanser but you can't go wrong with any
of them they're really really good
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough fa co v
fe fe pick your own DSE starter set for
just 5 bucks this is an unbelievable
deal for the quality of the stuff you
get after your starter set products ship
at regular price this is so much better
than using some rusty old blade that you
don't change for six months you don't
have to go to the drugstore you don't
forget about that just have them ship it
to you makes a lot easier take advantage
of our of the good aspects of our modern
world
dollarshaveclub.com cofee facio v fe fe
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough fa co v
fe fe you know before i thought we'd
have to grow out like a super long beard
and wear a sack cloth if they torpedoed
Cavanagh but now i'm gonna get
spick-and-span gonna shave put on my
Sunday best going out to a nice dinner
tonight so Delta shave club comm slash
go FFA Democrats have a new strategy now
they want Brett Kavanaugh to take a
polygraph test now I this is very funny
because there are for years and years
we've known the polygraph tests are
unreliable that's why we don't use them
as a matter of ascertaining guilt or
innocence and for so long the leftist
talked about false memories there are
there one professor who has been
interviewed a lot about this is
Elizabeth Loftus who talks about false
memories all the time her take on these
events has been a little leaning to the
left unfortunately but a lot of her work
and other people's work in this area
talks about how you can have false
memories that you are dead certain of
you know we've known that over time not
just over the course of 30 years but
even over the course of a short period
of time people's memories can change and
there are many ways to beat a polygraph
test there are many ways to be coached
on a polygraph test so this is there
this is their Hail Mary pass this okay
well now you know okay this is like the
second Hail Mary the Hail Mary of the
Hail Mary they say well now he's got to
take a polygraph test and here is brand
new brand spankin new cocaine Lindsey
Graham comes out to answer this
suggestion humiliated this
no bottom for somebody so why don't we
duck in the water and safety post why
don't we just dunk him and see if he
floats well I don't we'd like a perfect
witch trial now let's bring back the
Inquisition that's what Lindsey Graham
answers and it's a great way because
just really quickly let's sum up what
we've got
Brett Cavanaugh has nominated a couple
months ago he's got unimpeachable
character he nobody has questioned his
record of integrity he's been a federal
judge for a dozen years he was staff
secretary to the president he was
assistant independent counsel under Ken
Starr deputy independent counsel some
title like that worked on the Starr
investigation Yale Law graduate Yale
college graduate just a very serious guy
Georgetown Prep graduate as we've heard
ad nauseam just a very serious guy
totally milquetoast if you you know that
one wackadoodle a vanadis liar client
came out and said she she knows she
remembers Cavanaugh at the party because
he has a distinctive face he doesn't
have a distinctive face is the least
distinctive face I've ever seen you look
if you just said picked the most
milquetoast federal judge you can
imagine I would imagine Brett Kavanaugh
so that was him he gets nominated and
everything goes fun and they're all
upset about abortion they're all upset
about roe v wade they're all upset that
he's an originalist who believes the
Constitution means what it says they
were upset about his threat to Chevron
deference to the administrative state to
add up control big government but
remember the hearings went along just
fine we didn't hear a peep about this
nonsense until after the hearings were
over they knew he performed very well
all of a sudden Senate Democrats decide
at the 11th hour they're gonna spring
some bogus ridiculous accusations so
only after the hearings ended they
spring Christine Ford who says 36 year
35 or 37 years ago brick Cavanaugh was
in a room with four people or two people
at a party with five people or six or
seven people in some place she doesn't
know where she didn't know when it
happened or why or how the party came
about how she got home how she got there
but anyway the long and story short of
it is
he either groped her or he tried to kill
her something like that it kept changing
the story
kept changing on and on she said I I
know this is true because I'm afraid of
flying I have a fear of small spaces
that and I never fly because of this
incident that allegedly happened to me
from Brett Kavanaugh except I fly all
the time I fly to the French Polynesia
at a Hawaii or two here or there I take
trips all the time I fly in little
propeller plans okay but I the way you
know is that I'm so afraid of small
spaces that I demanded we have a second
door put on our home in 2012 when it
came up in marriage therapy with my
husband except actually it happened in
2008 and I did it for my marriage
counseling office and to rent it out to
college kids and to Google interns okay
well that doesn't add up you okay well
alright that's hey guys this forward
thing isn't really panning out is it
there's no corroboration well all the
people that I say were there just talk
to them all the people refute what she
says let's move on to someone else oh
okay Julie sweat Nick yeah yeah Brett
Kavanaugh he was he was a gang rapists a
criminal mob boss in whenever it doesn't
matter you don't it doesn't matter
nobody cares whether I'm true or not we
just want a torpedo Kavanaugh okay so
then it turns out Julie sweat Nick was
actually in college during the high
school parties actually she's a known
liar she's got a huge history of filing
false harassment sexual harassment
physical harassment claims okay that
one's not gonna work well we need
another FBI investigation okay we got
another FBI investigation they conclude
nothing okay okay here here we are
that's the say if you want to skip out
on two weeks of the news that's what
happened so now we are where we are and
this is what it's come to
and now all we have left is the left
evidence free sanctimony you know we
treat women what we believe women we
believe all liars hashtag believe all
liars
and the right doesn't believe women and
then cocaine Lindsay comes back you know
for the sucker punch right behind he
goes right here's a jab he goes back
with the hook when he is speaking it at
the Atlantic Festival here's what he
says here's how it was misinterpreted
and here's why it's a great job against
the left was a personal degrading attack
on someone well the private citizen no
here's what's personally degrading this
is what you get when you go through a
trailer park with Wonder
dollar bill I you see this is not the
first time this has happened that's
actually a reference to something
somebody said in James car so the guy
who's interviewing Lindsay he knows what
he's doing but the audience doesn't is
the audience are just regular
run-of-the-mill leftists who read the
Atlantic
so what Lindsey Graham here says because
they're saying it's so degrading what
Trump and the Republicans have done to
these poor women and Lindsey Graham says
you know it's degrading drag a
hundred-dollar bill through a trailer
park and see what you get the gasps hell
that's a really awful thing to say the
implication being that if you coax these
these unclassy women with some money
they'll make up allegations how dare
Lindsey Graham say this the left went
crazy they start running articles about
this they start tweeting about this but
then they realize that's not a Lindsey
Graham quote that is a James Carville
quote when he was a top adviser to Bill
Clinton and that was how he responded to
Paula Jones's accusations that Bill
Clinton sexually harassed her and
whipped it out and to about all of the
other women who came out and accused
Bill Clinton of sexual harassment and
assault and rape said drag a
hundred-dollar bill through trailer
parks see what you get so now all of a
sudden you could see I was watching it
in real time on Twitter yesterday
everything starts to change and the big
shift someone said Lindsey rim this is
he's actually saying just what James
Carville say uh whoops never mind whoops
because the sanctimony is absurd when
Democrats have the opportunity to smear
women who have a lot more credibility by
the way a lot more credibility than
Christine Ford and Julie sweat Nick or
whatever they're talking about now
whenever they have the opportunity to
smear them they do it Hillary Clinton
was put in charge of bimbo eruptions
their words not mine
they take that opportunity Republicans
don't do that we don't behave like that
and by the way when Republicans have the
opportunity to falsely accuse people of
gang rape criminal rings or whatever we
don't do it we never said Merrick
garland was some like leather daddy
criminal or something we just said we're
not we're not going to vote for him
because they don't have the votes and
we're not going to confirm and we're
gonna wait till the election but they do
that they don't the Democrats do not
take sexual assault varies
at all they don't take women very
seriously at all either now Lindsey
Graham is being accused of what about
ISM here what about ISM is perhaps my
least favorite phrase in politics it's
such a stupid word
what about ISM it's look there is a
legitimate what about ISM it's it's a
description of the to quote boy fallacy
which is when you try to distract from
somebody's point by bringing up some
some point about them
that's a I'm not saying that there is no
legitimate what about ISM argument or
whatever to quote boy fallacy but it's
so abused
what about ISM is what about ISM what
when you the word what about ISM is the
what about his and fallacy it's
especially in politics especially in
journalism I'll get to why in a second
before we do that let's talk about keeps
oh let's talk about keeps keeps is very
important it's designed for guys who
want to stop hair loss with their
scientific and affordable approach
managed entirely on keeps calm keeps us
the easiest way to stop hair loss before
it's too late I'm gonna be very honest I
don't think this is self effacing or in
any way I'm not an Adonis of a man I'm
not a gigantic guy I don't exercise all
the time you know I but I do have this
poufy head of hair which helps me pick
up the ladies and keep sweet little
Alisa sticking by me and not running
away leaving annalisa shaped hole in the
wall so it really works
keeps offers the only two fda-approved
hair loss products clinically proven to
keep the hair you have no BS just
science it's completely safe these are
generic versions of medications been
around for a while they're cheaper and
easier hair loss can start 25 30 35 you
can stop it but you got to stop it now
for a dollar a day or less sign up takes
five minutes answer a few questions snap
some photos 10 to 35 bucks a month less
than a dollar a day in most cases go to
receive your first month of treatment
for free keeps calm / co' f fa c OV e fe
f e ke e PS calm / go fa c OV e fe fe 3
month of treatment don't say never did
nothing for you
Keep Calm / go if FA Co the fe Fe keeps
here today hair tomorrow the what about
ism thing is really tired because in so
when you bring up what about ism here's
what happens someone said that that
Republicans are being degrading to women
and and this is awful and Democrats are
way better and that's why you should
vote for Democrats so Lindsey Graham
says Democrats are awful to women and
then the left says well that's what
about ISM that's not what about ISM I'm
pointing out your hypocrisy and in
politics and journalism the the most
important tool you have is setting the
discussion setting the agenda deciding
what is going to be talked about so if
the Democrats are just setting the
agenda and you're not allowed to call at
their own hypocrisy then you have no
tools at your disposal you lose one of
the the best tools that you have at your
disposal which is why I totally erases
what about ISM claims what about what
about ISM what about what a baptism
because the the minute you bring up what
you know they bring up the Republicans
are bad with women then the Republicans
bring up that the Democrats are bad with
women and then the Democrats say well
what about ISM what about what about ISM
well what about what about what about is
what about what about what about let's
focus on the issue at hand Democrats are
being sanctimonious hypocrites right now
they have no credibility on this issue
whatsoever we don't we don't owe them a
single answer so that is that's cocaine
Lindsey for you let's go down to cocaine
Mitch cocaine Mitch sums it all up he
says we are not scared beautiful display
from Senator Scarface bully and
intimidate members of this body I'm not
suggesting we're the victims here mr.
president but I want to make it clear to
these people who are chasing my members
around the hall here or harassing them
at the airports are going to their homes
will not be intimidated by these people
there is no chance in the world they're
going to scare us out of doing our duty
I don't care how many members they chase
how many people they harass here in the
hall I want to make one thing perfectly
clear we will not be intimidated by
these people
you tell them Mitch you tell him cocaine
Mitch that's absolutely right and that's
all it takes all it takes is
conservative standing up to the left and
saying you're not going to push us
around because the left is like the
opposite of sand people of sand people
in star wars you know the sand people in
Star Wars
they march in single-file line to hide
their numbers what the left does is they
get like three people to just jump
around everywhere they can to make it
seem like they have a zillion people
they have George Soros at the top but
many other Democrat and left-wing
operatives create all these little fake
accounts and fake organizations and fake
protests astroturf campaigns to make it
seem like they have a lot of people this
has been going on since by the way the
mid 20th century since we the left
controlled all of the news media they
made it seem like everybody had this
consensus everybody was vaguely
left-wing oh don't never mind that
Walter Cronkite is a world Federalist
never mind he's a strong left-wing
activist
no he's just these the voice of the
American people he's though he says the
Vietnam War is over America must have
lost faith in Vietnam no these guys are
a minority they've been doing this
forever the Bolsheviks say that they're
the majority they were the minority
they've been doing this the left has
been doing this for ever but they're not
in the minute that in though in the
television news media that fox news came
out Fox News became a huge smash hit why
because there's a huge percentage of the
population if not the majority of the
population that was not being
represented by these left-wing hacks
same thing on new media when the social
media came out all of a sudden the write
was totally emboldened why because that
mainstream media newspaper network TV
monopoly was cracked up for the first
time we got to get our voices out there
and people are listening people tuned in
and it rallies them this is exactly
right you know sometimes we get asked
how does everybody come together again
in America people were never together in
America I mean you know we love each
other because we're each other's
countrymen at least at least the right
feels that way I don't know if the left
feels that way anymore when they're
going and attacking Republicans children
at their houses at least the right feels
that way but we didn't agree we didn't
agree from the beginning of the country
we had opposing ideas about the country
Federalists and the anti-federalists now
the Republicans and the Democrats
the coming together again is you can do
it two ways you can do it with this fake
political consensus which is always put
on by the left or you can do it with the
traditional values that undergird the
country so I'm talking about religious
values and cultural values and watching
the same TV shows and listening to the
same movies but when it comes to the
politics of it all the newspapers the
news media the politicians if we all
come together what that means is
shutting up conservatives we had a half
century of that or more we don't need
any more of that whatsoever Mitch says
I'm not scared why is he not scared look
at the polls a new poll out of NPR PBS
Newshour Marist shows the den point
Democrats had a 10-point enthusiasm
advantage before this Kavanagh nonsense
that has evaporated is now statistically
nothing in July
78% of Democrats and 68% of Republicans
said that this election was very
important now the numbers increased
slightly for Democrats to 82% but it
shot up 12 points for Republicans to 80%
it's totally reinvigorated them how
about women enthusiasm for the Democrats
now after Kavanagh it the Democrats
thought that women were going to become
much more enthusiastic about voting
because of this Cavanagh circus they've
actually declined democratic women are
now two points less enthusiastic than
they were before Cavanaugh the GOP among
women shot up 12 percentage points from
71% to 83% Quinnipiac poll shows a 7
point Republican gain in local
congressional races GOP enthusiasm is
now at levels equal to 2010 that was the
last gigantic wave for the GOP
enthusiasm levels that high now I've got
a temper that because Democrat
enthusiasm levels are also very high
they've taken a hit but they're also
quite high right now so I'm not
predicting a 2010 election but I am
saying that cocaine Mitch has nothing to
be afraid of Republicans and
conservatives don't either when you
stand up when you stand for something
when you stand for what's right even if
you think it's unpopular I'm telling you
you will win you'll win in the long term
a strong majority of voters now of both
parties across both parties believe that
Brett Kavanaugh should be confirmed to
the Supreme Court flake looks good
Collins looks good we talked about that
earlier right now Heidi Heitkamp who's
an embattled Democrat senator she is
saying what she's going to vote no on
this this is not a surprise this is not
evidence of how other Democrats or swing
votes are going to go she's down 12
points in the polls and Cavanaugh has
really
hit her this whole Cavanagh thing has
really hit her in the polls she's down
12 points things are not looking good
for her I think she's voting no because
she's in for a penny in for a pound she
if she was gonna go down she's gonna go
down swinging and try to protect her her
legitimacy in the Democrat Party we've
got to go really quick but before we do
that I have to talk about this
disgusting clip that was going around
the internet I know we got to get to
mailbag I know we got to get to National
Poetry Day too bad because this clip is
once the this sums it up this sums up
the male feminist perfectly a there was
a pro-life rally and some left-wing he
for she I believe all women male
feminist decided to attack a pro-life
woman here is destruction of private
property see us a lot he gets raped by
somebody and they're like I was 16 year
old and I can't have this
I think you should keep it it's a baby
if someone is raped and she gave birth
and she decided to kill her
three-year-old child for those who
couldn't see this male feminist dressed
in his little hoodie with his little you
know signs and his backwards cap and it
was his stupid facial hair he's he winds
up and roundhouse kicks this girl and I
don't know where it might have kicked
her in the head because he kept right in
the screen right in where the camera is
this his name is Jordan hunt by the way
if you want to find him authorities I
guess he's still on the run or who knows
he's I don't think he's been apprehended
yet Jordan hunt this was at a pro-life
rally in Toronto that name again Jordan
hunt Jo our da n hu NT just in case you
come across the guy there's this picture
so this was a pro-life rally and this
guy wasn't a pro-abortion rally this
wasn't like the pro-lifers have crashed
a pro-abortion rally that wouldn't
excuse it either way but apparently it's
a pro-abortion rally this guy shows up
he's vandalizing people's signs because
the left is afraid of free speech and
then he just starts harassing this woman
and look obviously this guy is a creep
but and it's very creepy when men or big
abortion activists and that little
creepy and that a little you think well
what's your what's your interest in this
here is that only you're trying to evade
some responsibility you want to I don't
know what you want to pressure women
that's a little creepy
but there is nothing creepier than the
male feminist nothing creepier under the
Sun than the male feminist because with
what's so disgusting to us even before
he kicks her is that this is this is a
girly man this is what Arnold
Schwarzenegger means by a girly man when
we see a man behave like a girl
it's really weird we don't care when
girls behave like girls we don't care
when men behave like men maybe the left
does but when a man behaves like a girl
it's disgusting when he became like a
little catty girl the worst woman ish
not woman laid like this little catty
guy who thinks that he can beat up women
because he look we know civilized people
know that men should never hit women
meant men who hit women should be taken
out back put down like Old Yeller
we know that civilized people know that
but this guy doesn't know that because
he thinks men and women are the same
right they're all the same
I can behave like a like a hysterical
little girl no you can you shouldn't
it's much worse when you do that then
when a girl does that then when a woman
does that because male feminists like
this guy girly men lack all of the
natural virtues of manliness they don't
have any of the virtues of being a woman
of womanliness that so they have no
virtues they have none the natural
virtues that they could have they
abandoned it's it's really disgusting
that name again Jordan hunt if you
happen to be in Canada and come across
him okay I gotta say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube we had a lot of mailbag to
get to and then we've got the we've got
a lovely little poem that I think will
invigorate all of us especially on this
wonderful Thursday when we look at the
Supreme Court and we look around our
culture this Friday ele wire will be
launching the next chapter of Andrew
Flavin's podcast series another Kingdom
performed by little ol me Michael
Knowles this is you know the only times
I ever get to act anymore in Hollywood
or when Carolla
Praeger Ted Cruz or Andrew Klavan cast
me oh come see my probably last acting
performance ever or maybe we'll get
another season who knows it's really fun
this season if you're not caught up on
the first season it's gonna be available
on our website daily wire subscribers to
daily wire will get really access to
each episode all of it will be ad free
this season is really cool
last year we did the audio Andrew Sadek
it was just an audio podcast this season
we've added this really cool dramatic
visual element it enhances every aspect
of Drew's story which I got to tell you
is phenomenal he's one of the great
writers of his age I mean really
obviously you don't sell that many
bestselling novels and and make all
those movies if you're not an incredibly
talented writer this story is just
terrific
head on over to Daley wire.com and
subscribe also thanks for following us
on on iTunes and subscribing on iTunes I
was getting a lot of tweets yesterday
that people couldn't subscribe I don't
know it's so weird I can't imagine that
Apple whatever Apple which in 2016 and
91% of their political donations
to Democrats I can't imagine they'd be
messing around with me or anything but
make sure you go over to iTunes and
subscribe to the show we'd really
appreciate it really helps us out if you
could add some 5-star reviews that would
be really helpful and it would probably
irritate Ben which is an added bonus go
to daily wire comm you know what you get
you get all the shows and the mailbag
and all that you need this now you need
this now the vote for cloture is set for
Friday the vote to confirm Cavanaugh is
is Saturday I don't want to hear it I
don't want to hear it on Sunday well I
don't care the bubbles are gonna stop
buddy you got to get the leftist here's
tumblr or don't come crying to me when
you're falling down to Davy Jones locker
go to daily wire.com we'll be right back
with the mailbag and a little poetry
let's fly through them from Robert
question golden boy Knowles I've always
seen I've always been against the
two-party system I would like to see
either no parties or multiple parties
with just two I feel that it's just a
game of who has the bigger stick for now
what are your thoughts on this Rob I
love the two-party system it is the best
party system that there is I love it I
hear this all the time on the right in
the left I hate the two-party system I
think it's great
which party system would you prefer
would you prefer the one party system
that's totalitarianism
would you prefer a multiple party a
three party for party system where
little spoiler parties can go in and
totally subvert the will of the people
such that the least preferable party
comes into power
would you prefer a zillion party system
where demagogues are able to take hold
and corruption inevitably takes hold
I don't think so the two-party system
goes back to the earliest days of our
country ghost goes to before the country
was technically even founded or before
the government was founded we had the
Federalists and the anti-federalists
arguing over what our government should
look like the Federalists Hamilton
Madison J the anti-federalists led by
Jefferson then later we had the
Federalists and the Jeffersonian
Republicans the the Democratic
Republicans then we had the Whig party
come in now and now we have the
two-party system I think it's very good
it's good as long as you have a choice
and not an echo if the two parties
believe the same thing then that's
terrible and we've gone through periods
where that's the case but I think right
now the two parties are genuinely
offering you a different choice the
Republican Party after many hard-fought
years of the conservative movement is a
home for conservative thought and the
Democratic Party is a home to
anti-american leftism they're being
honest at least it's a choice and on an
echo and I'm a big fan of that I think
you should pick your party and you
should stick with the party so long as
the party is sticking with you from
Jeffrey hey Michael I was wondering do
you believe you contribute to your
salvation it's an interesting question
Jeffrey I think we should be more
specific in our language here I
certainly don't think that I earned my
salvation or that I deserve my salvation
but I do think that I can lose myself a
I do think that there is a that my
salvation can be taken away or that I
can lose it depending on how I behave
and I've got a lot of scriptural
evidence for this the Gospel according
to st. Matthew says he who endures to
the end will be saved what if you don't
endure to the end what if you say okay
now I'm saved and then you don't endure
to the end it seems that you won't be
saved how about this see then the
kindness and the severity of God
severity toward those who have fallen
but God's kindness to you provided you
continue in his kindness otherwise you
too will be cut off that's from Paul's
letter to the Romans you too will be cut
off if you don't continue in his
kindness from Matthew not everyone who
says to me Lord Lord shall enter the
kingdom of heaven
there seems to be something else that
you have to do we know that faith
without works is dead there seems to
have to be a fruit of the Spirit not
everyone who just says it gets into
heaven from the First Epistle of st.
John by this it may be seen who are the
children of God and who are the children
of the devil whoever does not do right
is not of God nor he who does not love
his brother so if you don't do right
then you're not of God this implies that
you have to do something that it's not
all ethereal and abstract and happening
in the mind that there's something that
you're doing with your body also from
first First Epistle of st. John for this
is the love of God that we keep his
Commandments and His commandments are
not burdensome sure his yoke is easy and
his burden is light
but we must keep those commandments of
God what are those commandments you'll
have to look into that won't you we
could have a whole long discussion about
that how about this I have fought the
good fight I have finished the race I
have kept the faith
henceforth there is laid up for me the
crown of righteousness which the Lord
the righteous judge will award to me on
that day second Timothy because he
finished the race and he kept the faith
also from st. Paul in the first letter
to the Corinthians or first Corinthians
I pummel my body and subdue it less lest
after preaching to others I myself
should be disqualified st. Paul
certainly seems to think that he could
lose his salvation that some
participation was required therefore my
beloved as you have always obeyed so now
not only as in my presence but much more
in my absence work out your own cell
with fear and trembling with hopeful
confidence in the promises of Christ
that's also from the letter to the
Philippians work out your own salvation
with fear and trembling I think
something the reason that I bring all
that scripture in is because I think
some time my very well-meaning friends
from various denominations try to make
false dichotomies between faith and
works or by not participating at all in
your and in the process of your
salvation we're losing your salvation or
of suggesting that we don't really have
any free will and this miss reads all of
that teachings of the church from the
very beginning and if miss reads
scripture to freedom matters and if
someone thinks that it's just so easy is
to snap one's fingers and to be saved
and never think about it again I would
recommend rereading st. Paul who says
that we he urges us all to work out our
salvation with fear and trembling also a
good book by soren kierkegaard keep
going to in a couple more before we get
to that poem from Colleen greetings to
the Daily wires resident Catholic I've
been mulling over comments that you've
made in the recent past about young man
is sowing their Wild Oats and the
indulgences you appeared to give them
for a living a reckless youth I firmly
believe in forgiveness and letting
someone's past be the past but wouldn't
it be better for that past to not be
there at all also if I am remembering
this correctly you seem to have a boys
will be boys attitude toward porn in
your Alex Jones trans porn segment a
while back if this is not your view
toward porn please set me straight
in a nutshell shouldn't sin still be
called sin and not be poo pood is a
growing experience that makes me me or
perhaps I don't understand since my
adolescent rebellion amounted to getting
a job to put myself through Catholic
private school rather than be
homeschooled
throughout my youth I had the boring sin
of pride to contend with and not the
more exciting sins of lust and
intemperance well you're missing out on
something let me tell you as someone who
had a little bit more than pride in my
my reckless youth yeah I'm not nobody is
saying that sin is a good thing if I'm
laughing at sin I'm not praising sin I'm
not adoring sin if I'm saying that you
know men are gonna look at porn in a
world where it's free and easily
available and is beamed endure how
I'm not saying that's a good thing or
that we shouldn't not look at porn or
that men you know I guess some women
look at porn too but it's mostly a male
thing or that we shouldn't you know take
every opportunity to leader to be led
away from temptation and to prevent
ourselves from near occasions of sin but
I am laughing at sin because I don't
spend my whole life quaking in fear of
sin I don't I don't really worry about
it I cuz my my redeemer lives and has
conquered death and so I do what I can
to avoid sin and I recommend that
everyone doesn't not just when they're
in their 20s or 30s or 40s but also when
they're kids and when they're teenagers
but I am pointing out that especially in
teenage years people are going to do
stupid things they're gonna boof and
they're gonna have brewskis with PJ and
squee and they're gonna do and they they
might even you know make an awkward pass
at a girl and they're gonna do those
things and I look no further for
evidence of this than st. Agustin father
of the church who famously said Lord
make me chaste but not yet this isn't to
say that sinning is a good thing that we
should encourage sin at all but the good
Lord can turn sin and conquer it and try
and turn it for good he can do that he
can turn you away from sin and for good
and you can participate in that as well
with your free will you know the
original sin the fall of man that pride
that caused man to fall out of the
garden we call it the Feliz culpa the
happy fall because God redeems mankind
because of the Incarnation and because
of the resurrection so I just don't
spend my life fretting over it as much
as perhaps some people do it's a bad
thing I don't I don't revel in the bad
things that I've done in my life and
then I'll continue to do and that'll
probably do tomorrow - I don't revel in
them at all I don't think they're good
at all I think they're really bad I look
on them with shame but one must look at
the the realities of how people behaved
yesterday and today and how young boys
and young girls are gonna behave
tomorrow and for all of eternity because
we're in a fallen world
but fortunately Christ has conquered sin
and you know some people are gonna gonna
ask the Lord to make them chaste sooner
rather than later just like st. Agustin
one more then we'll get to the poem from
Jason dear Michael I tremendously enjoy
your show but I'm ashamed of you
cocaine Lindsay really cocaine Lindsay
the man's last name is Graham gr a.m.
Graham you passed up the chance to call
him cocaine Graham for cocaine Lindsay
huh Jason I feel you Jason I totally
feel you I get it but one thing I've
learned from the Trump era in politics
is that subtlety doesn't always play I
know the cocaine Graham is better like a
gram of cocaine you know but if I said
cocaine Graham or Lindsey Graham as over
an M you people wouldn't get it
it wouldn't make that connection right
away it's kind of like folk ohonta s--
folk ohonta s-- is the funnier name for
Elizabeth Warren F aux contest Foca
Honda's but Donald Trump calls her
Pocahontas and Pocahontas stuck why
because Foca Honda's first of all you
have to know the word faux then you have
to see how it's being spelled in that
context then you have to realize you're
actually talking about two words just
doesn't work the left tried to do this
actually also with faux with faux news
for Fox News and it's just that it
doesn't work sometimes you get a
bludgeon people on the head especially
in politics especially when the politics
is murky as this so I got to stick with
cocaine Lindsey for now but I agree
cocaine Graham is funnier Lindsey Graham
is funnier I'll be able to think about
that well I'm just just celebrating him
and you know doing my little Scarface
stands for for Lindsey Graham 2.0 before
we leave it's national poetry day I love
poetry I love reading poetry people
don't really read poetry anymore I don't
even know if it's really taught in
school or if you have to memorize it in
school but I I was thinking what poem
should we read for National Poetry Day
what speaks to our current culture and
there's a great one by Henry Wadsworth
Longfellow called a psalm of life which
speaks to this moment that we're in this
scientism you know Longfellow was
writing this poem against the scien
scientism of his a
we've got a much worse scientism the
idea that everything is material nothing
really matters there's no moral order
there's no purpose to life life is a
tale told by an idiot full of sound and
fury signifying nothing and this just
isn't true and even on the other side
people who say oh even if you're really
religious and you realize that the soul
exists you say oh freedom doesn't matter
it doesn't it cares what we do and this
poem says not quite it's a great poem
too to read and memorize and think about
for our age a sum of life by Longfellow
what the heart of the young man said to
the psalmist tell me not in mournful
numbers life is but an empty dream for
the soul is dead that slumbers and
things are not what they seem
life is real life is earnest and the
grave is not its goal dust thou art to
dust returnest was not spoken of the
soul not enjoyment and not sorrow is our
destined to end or way but to act that
each tomorrow find us farther than today
art is long and time is fleeting and our
hearts though stout and brave still like
muffled drums are beating funeral
marches to the grave in the world's
broad field of battle in the bivouac of
life be not like dumb driven cattle be a
hero in the strife trust no future
however pleasant let the dead past bury
its dead act act in the living present
heart within and God or head lives of
great men all remind us we can make our
lives sublime and departing leave behind
us footprints on the sands of time
footprints that perhaps another sailing
or life solemn mane a forlorn and
shipwrecked brother seeing shall take
heart again let us then be up and doing
with a heart for any fate still
achieving still pursuing learn to labor
and to wait and now you will have to
wait until Monday when we come back
although you'll get to see the second
season of another Kingdom coming out
tomorrow be sure to go to daily wire.com
for that in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
I'll see you Monday
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018